[Music]  well if you ask me where I come from  here's what I tell everyone it's a place  that is even more free then Jameis  Winston's groceries with the Stars and  Stripes and a eagle fly  you can start the business of your  dreams if you pay all  last week I'm literally helping a guy  buy a futon kids windowsill lemon juice  yeah if their license forms have been  approved that guy's panhandling with the  Stars and Stripes  and the Eagle blood  lady that stands  for what we believe overlooking a guy  getting arrested for helping sightsee  to show somebody around you can pull  yourself from poverty all your needs a  bit of elbow grease and 1200 hours of  training 20 gray hair braids and a  permission slip from Uncle Sam  unbelievable where the Stars and Stripes  and they reply  where the Stars and Stripes and the  eagle  [Music]